chose 10 heures début le journal demain
21 juin bien ce sera l'été et pour fêter
son arrivée et monsieur jack lang le
missouri culture a eu l'idée d'organiser
une vaste fête de la musique demain
entre 20h30 et 21h vous êtes tous
invités à montrer vos talents de
musicien et puis après vous pourrez les
faire la fête il y aura des centaines et
des centaines d'orchestre un peu partout
dans les rues des villes et des villages
une manifestation qui s'annonce bien si
l'on en croit le ministre monsieur
jacques lang
nous l'écoutons à lire le courrier que
nous recevons chaque jour ici ce sont
des centaines de milliers de gens à
travers la france des petits des grands
des musiciens amateurs des musiciens
professionnels qui ont répondu avec
enthousiasme notre appel et je crois que
lundi prochain à 20h30
des centaines milliers de français
seront dehors avec leurs instruments de
musique sans complexe pour célébrer la
naissance de l'été et je crois que cet
immense armée des musiciens français
montrera sa force ce soir là elle vient
aux places publiques dans les kiosques
dans les rues au pied son domicile à sa
fenêtre
est ce bien le rôle de l'état que
d'organiser de telles fêtes qui si nous
n'y mettons guère habitués n'organisons
pas audi simplement
libre à chacun de témoigner par son
instrument de musique de sa joie à voir
l'été revenir mais vraiment il n'ya pas
d'obligation et chacun est libre on
entend ça en ce moment les canes ont
entonné un peu partout on entend aussi
les monnaies s'entrechoquer est ce bien
le moment d'art et d'essai défaite mais
je crois que si on veut gagner les
batailles contre la dépression contre le
chômage pour la réanimation économique
du pays il faut avoir confiance en soi
même et il faut que les forces de vie
toutes les forces de vie il est fort de
l'intelligence des forces de la joie les
forces de l'expression se met en branle
au fond la vie c'est un tout et
l'économie la culture c'est un tout et
un pays morose un pays déprimé ce n'est
pas un pays et bataille économique
et si nous sommes en mesure de
trouver en nous mêmes la force de rire
nous aurons aussi en nous mêmes la force
de lutter contre l'inflation et de
lutter contre le chômage
ce n'est pas en pleurant et en gémissant
qu'on gagne la bataille économique
c'est au contraire en croyant à nous
mêmes et en croyant aux fortes
extraordinaire d'un pays comme la france